there's a lot of buzz coming out of
Tiff's a star is born Lady gaga having
as an actor and someone who has
supported her how does it feel to see
her have this moment I'm only proud
Taylor Kinney fully supports his ex Lady
Gaga as she shines bright in her new
role on the big screen almost every
single person has told me they liked the
way I sounded but that they didn't like
the way I look I think you're beautiful
just destroyed every single scene you
were in mother Monster was actually
moved to tears at the Toronto Film
Festival after receiving a standing
ovation for her performance in a star is
born she did what it takes to make this
et caught up with Gaga and her co-star
Bradley Cooper at the festival where
they dished on the making of their new
musical drama
[Applause]
tell me about the first moment Bradley
contacted you about playing this role
and what it meant to you and what you
talked about well I actually was
performing at a cancer fundraiser for
Sean Parker and I sang the song levy on
Rose which not to give it away but it is
in the film and I sang that song and the
very next day he wanted to meet me and
he came over to my home and I opened the
door and the second I looked into his
eyes I felt an instant connection to him
and before I knew it he said I would
like to sing with you if that's okay and
we went to the piano and I printed out
the sheet music for a song that he
wanted to sing called midnight special
and I sat down and started to play and
he began to sing and I just stopped
instantly in my tracks and I looked at
him and I said Bradley you have an
incredible voice you sing from your gut
you sing from your soul you sing from
the nectar of your being that's all you
can ask for for a singer as someone that
can tell a story and then he said should
we film it so he filmed it on his iPhone
and he's all of a sudden started to sing
together and harmonizing and laughing
and looking at each other it was
instantaneous and I knew in this moment
that I could make this film with him
[Music]